McDonald's was a big paycheck for
Michael Jordan throughout his career and
if you believe his teammate Charles
Oakley MJ also ate at McDonald's every
morning for breakfast McDonald's even
named a meal after him the mcjordan
special it was a quarter pounder with
bacon and barbecue sauce with a drink
and a side of fries in 1992 Michael
Jordan helped make a training video with
McDonald's for their staff here is that
very video enjoy and let me know what
you
think hi I've got something very new and
special that I really like for you to
see it's a video about satisfying the
customer called doing whatever it takes
now you're probably wondering what does
Michael Jordan know about satisfying the
customer well let me tell you when I
step onto the basketball court those
18,000 screaming people aren't just fans
they are my customers they want to see
more than just a basketball game they
expect to see a show no matter what kind
of day I've had when I put on that
uniform my customers are expect behind
the back passes long three pointers or
great slam dunks it's my job to deliver
it and I love it when you put on your
McDonald's uniform your customers want
more than just quick service with a
smile they expect to be treated as a
guest in your home and if you hadn't had
the greatest of days it's up to you to
put on a show and do whatever it takes
to satisfy your customer the video you
about to see was show you the difference
between good service and great
personalized service we all must give
our customers and it will take you
behind scenes to show you how a video is
actually made so let's see what it means
to satisfy your customers by do whatever
it
[Music]
[Applause]
takes tape's rolling everybody set slate
please take one
Dolly and action thank you come
again
hi how can I help you whoa cut hold it
excuse me Jem come on that's the wrong
line help me out here you're supposed to
say hello welcome to McDonald's may I
take your order please that's the way
you always say it oh Dave sorry but
that's my
fault well I was talking to Jim a little
bit earlier and he said that he was
feeling really stiff having to say
welcome to McDonald's welcome to
McDonald's over and over again so I told
him what we tell our people all the time
uh say what feels natural but say it
with a warm sincere
smile I thought it was great well you're
the real manager here Barb you should
know I'm just not used to letting the
actors change the lines oh I understand
believe me I used to be the same way
when it came to letting the crew people
think for themselves uh say everybody
take a quick break okay what do you mean
oh well you know we have our operations
and training manual yeah well it's kind
of like your script it tells us how to
do things the right way at McDonald's
well I used to insist that all of my
team do everything strictly by the book
I mean everything from the way they
greeted the customer to how they took
the order and so on well I started to
notice that everybody seemed a little
stiff I mean really inflexible in the
way they were serving the customers and
the customers weren't uh particularly
responsive either so I decided that I
really needed to call a meeting I needed
to talk about this right Lisa you were
part of the team well yeah yeah we
kicked it around and everybody agreed
and we just didn't feel natural
constantly repeating the same thing so
we decided to lighten up a little like
um like ad lib a bit when we were
serving people and it worked it really
did people's personalities started to
show through I mean they well they
really started to have fun and the
customers they really enjoyed being
treated like individuals too you know
that really makes sense it's like well I
know that actors sometimes need to add
Li a line or two it makes their
performances more natural but I just
don't want to violate any McDonald's
operating procedures oh well no don't
worry about that our procedures are
mostly in the areas of work routines and
methods and those have been developed
throughout the years to make us work
more efficiently but when it comes to
how we treat our customers what we want
to impress them with our friendliness
our service and we can't do that if we
come on like robot right well sure okay
let's uh try that scene again and this
time everybody loosen up a little bit
okay places
everyone take two okay everybody the
entire scene now
Dolly and action thank you come
again hi how you doing may I take your
order yes uh how about a f of fish uh H
french fries and a small Coke please
will that be a large fry sir yes please
for here yes for here all right your
total comes to 319 I'll be right back
with the order thank
you and cut all right look good to me
how about you Barbara mm it's looking
better better well it it still seems a
little stiff to me um now I like the
opening and then it starts to get a
little
formal uh now maybe could your customer
be a little more
normal normal yeah uh maybe a little
less polite oh okay okay Mr customer
this time take three and action thank
you come
again hi what can I get for you today
yeah I want a fillet of fish french
fries and a small Coke and nothing else
okay well will that be for here to go oh
no what's wrong Lisa when a customer
comes on strong like that
we we've really got to handle him with
with kid gloves people like that are
almost always looking for a fight true
like they say turn the other cheek now
the next time this guy comes in he could
be one of your nicest customers if you
treat him right today you're right makes
sense got that Jim let's try it
again and action thank you come
again hi what can I do for you today
yeah I'd like a fet of fish a small Coke
and a fry and nothing else okay is that
a large fry I said a small fry well I'm
sorry sir I didn't hear you is that for
here yeah it's for here all right your
total comes to 278 I'll be right back at
the order and cut great well what did
you think that was a lot better you know
sometimes it takes that little bit extra
to avoid confrontation right Lisa boid
is it ever but it's worth it okay let's
set up for the night
[Music]
now the action here is Jim you're taking
this lady's order and you're going to
ask a special favor of Jim and that's
just the way I want it to sound like
you're you're almost reluctant to ask
okay all right background people keep
that energy up roll
tape and speed slay
in take
one and action hello what would you like
today well I'd like a medium Coke and a
Big Mac for here please would you like a
medium fry with that no not really but I
don't suppose it's possible for them to
put a slice of tomato on that Big Mac is
it yes ma'am it certainly is possible
it'll take just a moment is that okay of
course great that comes to 253 I've got
your Coke thanks we'll get your Coke now
you can find a seat and we'll bring your
Big Mac out to you thank you and
cut Barbara can I ask you something sure
now I understand the scene but are you
sure you want to show that in the video
well Dave I hear you but you know that's
what this whole video is all about when
we say doing whatever it takes that's
what we mean we want each customer to
leave thinking hey McDonald's did
something special just for me that's
[Music]
great really I don't know how you do it
I mean you got to remember all of your
lines and remember your action
and still smile hey from what you've
told me and from what I've read in this
script our work is a lot aik I mean
we're both performers we have to
remember a lot of things but face an
audience and we both need to
smile now the only difference is my
audience is is the camera and the
director and if I don't get my lines
exactly right I can do them over and
over until the director yells cut that's
a keeper then I feel as if I've done a
good performance but you you only get
one shot with each of your customers wow
I guess I never thought about it like
that but but you're right I mean I've
got to do all those things right the
first time mhm oh and it's a great
feeling when customers look pleased and
say thank you I figure if they smile at
me and thank me I've done a great job
and even if they don't I know I gave it
my best exactly okay places everyone
we're going to rehearse the lobby scene
great
thanks okay Jean you're the customer I
want you to set your tray down and take
a seat got it and then just as she sits
down Lou you show up with the gorilla
right okay uh then while you're talking
this gentleman at the next table right
folds up his newspaper okay gets up and
uh and leaves this way right all right
then you go over and clean off the table
get the TR right right okay everybody
else just uh
act natural eating talking with each
other you know having a good time okay
let's run through one time for the
camera okay
okay and
action ma'am here's your egg MC muffin
without cheese well that was fast thank
you no
problem and cut okay hey looks real good
any thoughts Barbara Lisa it was good
but it's missing something I think what
do you mean I don't you know I see
something that could really show the
kind of doing whatever it takes we're
talking about yeah well speak up that's
what you're here for all right now when
Lou comes in with the grill order the
guy sitting at the next table should
remain seated until here's your eggc
muffin without cheese well that was fast
thank you no problem Oh sir can I take
that tray for you oh yeah sure here you
go hey was everything okay with your big
breakfast this morning yes yes it was
have a great morning you too thank
you nice idea Lisa thanks it
plays but uh come on is that the way it
really
happens sometimes all right all right
not often enough but that is what we
want our people to understand from this
video right that they need to look for
situations where they can impress people
with our service and we need to use our
heads no do whatever it takes exactly
okay we need to think of our customers
at McDonald's like they're our own
personal guests and treat them that way
too but you know it's a shame you don't
even get to see the real stars of this
scene what are you talking about the
grill team well they're the ones who got
that Grill order out there so fast what
does the grill team have to do with
service oh the grill team has everything
to do with customer service you see if
they don't respond quickly in all
situations especially Grill orders then
the counter people could never deliver
the customer satisfaction we're shooting
for everyone in the store has to do
their part it's the teamwork that gets
the job
[Music]
done Hi how are you doing today okay
your total's 485 all right here you go
out of
five
your change is 15 cents enjoy your lunch
come back and see us real soon I got to
get out of the car now don't worry about
it I'll have somebody else get it
later here your ERS ready the next
window and have a nice day thanks thanks
a lot thank
you so what what were you say I wanted
to talk to you about sorry I had lived
at last it just seemed like the right
thing to do oh no it was great really
are you sure uhhuh you know well that's
what we're always trying to get our
people to do think on your feet I liked
it just it was great seem to be a
natural at
this okay everybody this is the final
scene and let's make it good this is the
perfect service scene everybody know
their business yep okay places everyone
roll
tape slay
in take
one and action
well hi there what can I get this hungry
troop today I clean my so I that's right
and I can good for you um a hamburger
and milk here and a cheeseburger Happy
Meal with milk for Jennifer uh and I'll
have a six piece McNugget with sweet and
sour sauce and a small d c for
here I got it good your total will be
be give lady the
money lady
money 668 out of
seven I'll get it py
meal oh I think Jennifer is hungry
that's right I'll get the cups for the
mil thanks ma' would you like a high
chair or booster seat with that uh a
booster seat would be great thank you
very much you're welcome
Jennifer and you got that you
go well now Jennifer you come back and
see us real soon and uh I don't know
your name Peter Peter will you do Peter
enjoy your lunch than so much I'll carry
that man' oh thank you very much you're
welcome
ready what did you think was that last
scene the perfect service scene it was
very good service but remember
throughout the video there was always a
way to improve the script to add lib
something that turned the expected
McDonald's service into complete
customer
satisfaction and I know you can do an
even better job than the actors because
you know the system you've got the power
to make things better if we rated what
you just saw as a service we're shooting
for a plus service the smiles the
friendly treat them as guest gestures
let our guests know
we're not just sixsteps and a smile our
goal is to make our guests think hey
these McDonald's people really care
about me and you know what we really do
but we have to do it every time even if
it takes a little bit more time when you
notice a guest not getting that great
McDonald's service whether it's a
quality problem an error with their
order or they just need a ketchup packet
help them quickly in doing so in earning
those smiles and thank you use and
repeat business we can make our jobs
more
fun now let's take another look at that
last scene even though it may have been
good service there are always ways to
improve on customer
satisfaction look for ways in which you
would improve our service I know you can
remember when it comes to customer
satisfaction it's okay to do whatever it
[Music]
takes
well hi there what can I get this hungry
troop
today that's right and I get one too for
you um a hamburger and milk here and a
cheeseburger hacking meal with milk for
Jennifer uh and I'll have a six piece
McNugget with a sweet and sour sauce and
a small D Coke for
here I got
a your total will be
hey give B the
[Music]
money 668 out of
seven I'll get it py meal yeah oh I
think Jennifer is hungry that's right
I'll get the cups for the milk thanks
man' would you like a high chair or
booster seat with that uh a booster seat
would be great thank you very much
there you
go well now Jennifer you come back and
see us real
S I don't know your name Peter Peter
Well you too Peter enjoy your Lun than
so much I'll carry that ma' oh thank you
very much you're welcome ready
[Music]
honey because you made it this far in a
video I want to celebrate you most
people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you are different you are
special believe Nation you made it here
all the way to the end and I love you so
as a special celebration if you put a
hasht believe down in the comments Below
on this video I will showcase you and
celebrate you somewhere on the screen in
a future video because you are awesome
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there to watch the top 10 rules video I
did on Michael Jordan check the video
right there next to me I think you'll
love it continue to believe see you back
every day the first person there before
the sun would be Jordan and he was there
because he wasn't good he would work
with a batting instructor and work all
day long